we're extremely pleased to have with us
today father miguel descotto
who is the minister of foreign affairs
for the nicaraguan government
during the sandinista regime father
descotto was
born in california in 1933 to nicaragua
and parents and returned to live in
nicaragua at the age of one
he attended secondary school in
nicaragua but then returned to the
united states
for his undergraduate studies he earned
his ba
in 1956 at maryknoll college and his m.a
in religious education at the marionel
seminar in new york
and was ordained a marinol priest in
june of 1961.
in 1962 he received an ms and
comparative journalism from columbia
university's
pulitzer school of journalism in 1962
father descartes went to cuba to chile
where he founded the institute for
neighborhood action
and research in santiago and served
there for some years
father descartes also became involved
with the sandinista front
for the national liberation of nicaragua
in the late 1970s
in 1977 he helped form the group
of 12 that composed of professionals
and intellectuals who supported the
liberation movement in nicaragua
after the victory of the sandinista
front in july
of 1979 he was appointed to serve the
newly formed government
as the foreign minister of nicaragua and
held that position
until after the 1990 elections so we're
extremely pleased to have you with us
today miguel thank you for coming
thank you for inviting us what we want
to do is to kind of provide you with a
historical perspective on
nicaragua and the sun and easter
revolution what they accomplished
and what has happened since then uh
father miguel can you give us a bit more
information on
the origin of the sandinistas the fact
that it was
particularly what not particular
organization but a front they called it
a front what does that mean
you know it's not really a front
in the usual
sense of the front means several
organizations that merge and come
together
differently santinista in that sense
although we called it the front
we called it the front because we
imitated the name from algiers
from the national liberation front
of algiers right and we copied that we
were inspired they are our young people
and they copy
that name but to make it nicaragua and
since we were
inspired on the thought of sandino we
call it sandinista national liberation
front but it's not a front in the sense
that it is not a collection
of several groups that merged it was one
from the very beginning
it was inspired and the action of
sandino sandino was a patriot
who back in the late 20s
fought for the explosion of the
marines from nicaragua nicaragua had
been occupied
by the united states practically since
1909 1910
when they overthrew the president
and then began sent marines to nicaragua
to hold the people down as they were
protesting
because they wanted to determine their
own destiny
and so at any rate sandino
fought for that and in 1933
on the 1st of january the marines left
and they had left behind them
the national guard an organization that
they had founded
after the model of what they had already
done in the dominican republic
ten years before and many american
observers were saying
don't do that in nicaragua because you
will
this fellow that you're appointing to be
the head of the national guard
is going to become a second trujillo and
that's exactly what happened
samosa somosa the first heads of the
nicaragua national guard were
american generals and then when they
left they appointed somosa
and one of his first tasks
was to get rid of sandino sandino had
retired to the mountains in northern
nicaragua he had established this
farmers cooperatives in wee wee lee
it's a mountain town 300 families
he had been invited to come down to the
presidential palace in manawa for a
banquet in his honor
after the banquet as he was coming down
that hill
he was ambushed and taken away and shot
and then they went to the house of the
minister of agriculture
sophonias albaterra who was his host
that's where santino was staying
overnight with the other people who came
with him
and they killed everyone else who was
there too
and then they went to wee willy and they
wiped off killed all of the
the people who belong to the cooperative
hoping in that manner to
to raise forever this
nationalistic spirit and this fight for
sovereignty and independence and
among our people but then you know as
they said in the early church
this seed the blood of martyr is the
seed of converts
so we saw sprouting all over the place
los as we say the cubs of
sandino and different sandinista
was formed again in 1960
and it grew and grew and grew until
the man who was to become the president
of nicaragua daniel ortega
was freed from prison
in 74
1974 and
he led our country first of all to
to plan for the final insurrection he
was only 28
he had been in jail that last period for
seven years
he had initially gone to jail the first
time when he was 14.
he is a catholic and devout catholic and
he said that he could not be
faithful to christ when he was 14 if he
watched was folded arms what was
happening to the people and he became
involved he became engaged in activities
against the somos
dynastic dictatorship which was horribly
brutal
by any standards what attracted you
initially
to join the sandinistas and what were
some of your first experiences
with the movement well
first of all let me divide it into parts
what
attracted me to santino
you must know first of all that in
nicaragua it was virtually impossible
to get any documentation in the books on
sandino
nicaragua may be well the only country
in all of
latin america or maybe the world as far
as i know where you don't have
sources historical sources at the
national library on your own country
one of the methods that somosa used
to in his process of domestication
it was to to make sure that people did
not have pride in their own identity or
even
had a sense of their own identity and so
but i began at age 12 collecting books
at age 13 i left my country for 36 years
and all over the world i looked for
books today i have the most complete
library of nicaragua matters
i learned that way about sandino
sandino became known to the world to
latin america through a great man
from argentina who died only recently in
mexico gregorio censer
he wrote several books on sandino
and what attracted me to sandino
is that he i found it very attractive
that he loved
the american people in spite of the fact
that he our country was victimized
by the american government and i found
that extremely
appealing this man who really
didn't have that much education he knew
how to read and
he was sophisticated enough to make a
distinction
between the official policy of a
government
and a people and his brother socrates
sandino
it was sent on several locations to the
states
generals and they know to speak before
solidarity groups there were many
here in philadelphia was a great big one
in chicago and new york
i mean brooklyn down not in miami miami
wasn't
much of anything then but in los angeles
and like that
and so that attracted me to san diego
but
and of course the cause but
i never knew
that i knew anyone who was a member of
the friend of sandinista remember i
didn't live in nakatawa
right i i was a missionary in chile
and then in the states i was director of
communications for maryknoll in new york
and as far as i knew when i wrote the
introduction to the
history of the national guard of
nicaragua
i do mention different sandinista but
when i wrote that i never knew that i
knew anyone who was a member
because people didn't come up to you and
say hi i'm a member that was a
clandestine organization
and then i was called and one by them
i was called in 75 75
and i you know
i had to go and first i said look
i don't know if i can i admire you for
what you're doing but i'm committed
to non-violence not that i want to
deprive anyone
or any people of the right
to use any means to save their life
because of the church's negligence we
never really took an element of the
gospel seriously which is
a the spirituality of struggle of
non-violent struggle
and we therefore allow the cancer of
injustice
to grow to such dimensions that it makes
it inevitable that eventually you have a
big
blob i had been influenced very much in
the united states by dr martin luther
king
the greatest influence in my life of a
contemporary
later on through king i went to gandhi
so
it's from christ to king to gandhi
and but
they told me well father we know exactly
they had well documented
everything that i had said and written
and he said but we want this ingredient
he says we are not militarist and we are
not violent
and but we're going to fight and
we wanted to help us to just to help us
to establish the direction in which we
must go
to really create an authentic democracy
you know that word so dirtied
by the likes of reagan or bush
the pharisees of western democracy
it's a good word and we must
and we have been working to rescue it
because it means empowerment of the
people
it means people through it it's not only
politically what i would call a
political expediency
this is a moral religious imperative
to work so that the people
have the reigns or
their own destiny and so they asked me
to
help them and to work with him so i said
i'll probably get in trouble with the
church
but i don't want to get in trouble with
our lord on that day of reckoning so i
accept i will not walk onto jericho and
lead you bleeding by the roadside
and so i got involved and then it grew
and then danielle said now you met my
foreign minister i said daniel please
let me go to the slums
where i have always worked no excuse me
was this
after they had kicked samosa out or were
they still fighting in the jungle
in the mountains no when i when i was
brought in first
is when we were fighting before the
insurrection before the final
i was brought in as a member of the
frenzy but then
when somosa was still there
remember we named the junta a government
although he's still there
and then daniel named me for a minister
before the revolutionary carried through
as such i spoke at the organization for
american states
in that historic 17th consultative
meeting
where the united states had in the last
moment when they realized that the
centenistas were going to overthrow
somosa
they wanted to have a green light for
american intervention
and the way they do that is they get an
approval for a
descending of inter-american
peacekeeping force
which is really an american invasion
with a little camouflage of some token
representation from other countries as
they had done in the dominican republic
exactly
and well with the help of god
we managed to obtain the greatest defeat
ever
uh for the united states
at what had been to then the ministry of
colonies
the oas that was the turning point right
where were you on the eve of the
revolution were you still in the united
states or had you returned to
nicaragua on the eve of the overthrow of
some yes
right i was well totally involved i was
already acting as the firm
minister of the of the sandinista
national liberation front
and like were you living in nicaragua no
no i had 30 years prison sentence
in nicaragua so i lived in nicaragua but
i was one night here two nights there
on the ground and yeah and yeah i had
i was a member of the group of 12 you
remember and we got this
so but
i was all over and never stopped
traveling
right so what was it like uh samosa left
and suddenly you are the foreign
minister
what were the feelings and the
experiences of the early days
and what was it like suddenly heavens
you're the foreign minister of
a new government a liberated country and
you yourself now our foreign minister
and have to deal with the foreign
ministers of other uh
countries particularly a lot of those
that had oppressed your people
i never
was so much like thinking you know like
i'm the foreign minister i'm thinking
the people are suffering there and and
this is what we have to fight for in
this uh
meeting and this is the objectives here
and that and
and we were quite successful and the
united states
tried to pin four against one
and then they came to the conclusion
that the reason why the four couldn't
trap us
is because as secretary of state
hegg said latino central american
foreign ministers are superstitious
they're too they're catholics and
superstitious and they don't want to
come
on full force against
a foreign minister who happens to be a
priest right and kirkpatrick said it was
most unfair of the sandinista to put a
priest
because because that somehow inhibited
the other
people from and and they even sent
messages one message
through the mexicans to tell us
that the relations would be better
if they changed they took me out and i
was there when daniel got the message
and the mexicans said look we are not
messengers of you that they told us
right says you tell them you find
someone else but they did tell us
did you have some direct dealings with
gene kirkpatrick and hague and some of
the thugs
remember i had those two those two
debates with jenkins patrick on
television
and after the first one she said she'd
never do it again and she
she was at a disadvantage that was on
nightline
and then on nightline and then i
but and then ted said well we'll never
he'll never get us together again but he
did remember
because the second time he got out of it
by saying that i was in a buenos aires
and that she was in in washington or in
new york or something
and but anyways we did that second one
and
who else did you ask whether i met the
hag oh sure
yeah i met oh yeah he was a bit of the
wall
i mean hag really something really
i remember i met him in st lucia and
there's
much publicized
encounter between him and i by all
americans there were all the
abc cbs nbc they had two crews one to
cover him
and one to cover me and the whole thing
that they covered about the
the oas meeting in saint lucia in the
caribbean country
was this and i remember well when i
first saw him
so i came to sit in that great big table
where the
ministers said it was across from me
he kept trying to to intimidate me by
eyeing me down you said by giving me
this god
and then i kind of enjoyed me
talking with him but i say he said he
was a bit
something then you get this schools and
that's a pitiful thing because schulz
was not really
a member of the inner circle of
president reagan
that doesn't function when you have a
foreign minister it must be the closest
person to the
if you're going to have a good foreign
policy and that
fortunately was my case in nicaragua has
always been with daniel where the
closest
any two people can ever be but in the
time of president reagan the real
foreign minister
for the main international
issue of president reagan was this other
madman
abraham uh edith and oliver north they
were basically
running they were the ones against your
country they were the ones who had the
access
right whenever they wanted to they could
go down to schultz
and she will saying have the guts to
oppose something he had in his heart he
knew
was wrong but he also knew how attached
how obsessed how pathologically obsessed
a reagan was
right to the overthrow of daniel of the
sandinistas
even though the san andreases weren't
anywhere near being communists as a
matter of fact the communists were
opposed to the san andreas communist
party communist party oh sure
the government's party was opposed all
the time
during our struggle against samosa and
during our government and now yeah right
can we go back and
pick up our story as to what the sun and
easters did when they took power
what was it they tried to accomplish and
what is it they did accomplish
well immediately any revolution
if it's an authentic revolution in ours
was
at the core of our purpose is
the people's power democratization
and that implies automatically er
the the development of respect for human
rights
political political civil economic
cultural and
social and we began
our first effort had to do with
we saw all this energy that the
combatants
against somalis ahead and we we said
we've got to
harness that is that the word we've got
to
take advantage of that energy and change
rifles with pencils
and we told them okay now we are going
to struggle against another enemy
one of the worst is ignorance and
illiteracy and we had that
one hundred thousand army
fighting against illiteracy in one of
the greatest
ever in history campaigns against
illiteracy in the alphabetization
campaign
we emphasize education very much we
doubled the number of students in our
country from half a million
to one million now things are
slowly going back to pre-revolutionary
days
but we did manage to double it health
service for the first time in our
history
was going beyond the city limits
into the rural areas and into the
mountains
and this uh outpost
were the prime targets of the
reagan-sponsored
contras they killed doctors and
destroyed the little
buildings and also killed teachers and
destroyed
schools the same and they
the other priority was
the democratization of ownership
we had a concentration in the hands of
few
we made new owners
over the whole period about
120 000 families
who became new owners
percentage-wise in our country that's a
large number of people
we brought unionism that was
theoretically allowed but god forbid if
you try to
organize with the rural workers
it was never possible we made it
possible
and pluralism of political parties
before that there
could not be more political parties
beyond the samosa
in order to to the constitution said you
could
but it said you needed to show
uh 30 000 members
and you have to get 30 000 you have to
give a list
of all these people and then they would
take some
parties tried it especially the
christian democratic party
and they were told after they presented
a year after
many of these people are dead and we
have not been
able to collaborate and so they never
got it
we said all you need to establish a
political party
is to give us the names of
the divorce the directors
of the in in nine provinces
uh so with 45 p members
theoretically you could have a party
because you have
you know the president and over the
chairman and the vice chairman and the
treasurer and two vocalists
that's a board and then that five times
nine is four to five and so we do have
too many i think but that's natural and
eventually
i think it's going to go down to less i
hope
during your first elections the american
people don't realize it but the big
election which the united states
intervened so heavily on uh the most
recent one
was not the first election there was an
84 wasn't it
and this was actually the first free
and the last free election that
nicaragua has ever had
and you wanted tremendous uh victory in
and it was also the
most observed election to date of any
independent nation we had observers from
all over the world and they all
testified to the fact of how it was
carried out and there were what there
were seven or eight parties at
seven parties but the united states as i
was told by
i think i can say it i was not
speaker jim wright recognized to me
speaking with him in his office he says
father
we know it we know that i mean our
government
told cruz not to run
so and to say that he couldn't run
because there weren't conditions to
guarantee his safety or the fairness of
the election
and so the united states said there
wasn't it wasn't good elections because
that
was being uh prevented from running
and as and by this time arturo cruz
himself has
speaking around in this country has
confessed to that it was
all sham a very
typical us government
behavior because i'm sorry to say but
it's so evident that lying and deceit
systematic lying in the city are the
main tools
of u.s foreign policy they lie to
that's why i worry so much about
american democracy
democracy requires an informed
citizenry in fact there's something else
very interesting on
the very night of the nicaraguan
election where there was also an
election
in the united states about at the same
time
it was presented on american television
that some soviet
migs were being sent down to nicaragua
that this was a
soviet military threat to central
america
later it turned out this was a
disinformation story
the sandinistas were in the process of
winning a big election victory
a democratic election and the reagan
administration wanted to cover over
this fact and to present a negative
image of what was going on in nicaragua
rather than a positive one
so they told this story that was leaked
to the television networks who then
presented it as a
fact um were you were you watching the
american television when you heard i was
watching this story and how did you
react to this
uh well it's a disinformation campaign
of a classic source
i expect nothing less from this
government
but you know the words of it all is not
only that that they are telling the
american people
that they are concerned that nicaragua
is becoming like a
great military power in the united
states is concerned
that nicaragua was going to invade the
neighbor
you see and that and that because of
that the united states had to send more
arms down there
to the neighbors the fact is
not only that the united states was not
concerned about that but they were
angry that we did not fall into the
traps
into the trap of going and invading
because let's we had invaded costa rica
to what a veil
what possible benefit could have accrued
to nicaragua for doing that crazy thing
we would hold it for about three hours
or three and a half hours
and then have served in a silver platter
what they were dying to get
an excuse because even if our
if we had done something which under
international law we could have done
we just go right after the basis of the
enemy
under international under the right of
imminent defense you could do that and
also had pursuit but
but they wanted us to fall into the trap
and they what they were angry
about and concerned about is that we
were not invading
so it was a real diabolical lie
just like when they said that that we
were getting too close to the
soviets that wasn't the concern
they wanted us to get closer because
that's why they went
trying to put pressure in europe and in
latin america
to cool it with nicaragua they wanted to
leave us in such a situation that we had
no alternative
but to turn to those countries that were
not permeable to american pressure
to give us what we needed to keep living
oil and things like that
and so
i tell you this country is the plague on
humanity
and i really pray i mean what is the
future
we recently met with president adias
and did the president ascona daniel and
myself and signatories of the central
american peace treaty
i wish you had been there with your
camera to tape that meeting
some social scientists were indeed in
fact invited
to hear the and it was really
interesting they were really saying
why they behaved the way they behaved
how what kind of pressures they were
under
right how they knew it was batting but
they didn't know what to do because the
pressures were huge
and um and then we were talking
about the third day of meetings we were
three days
the third day was what does the future
hold
and and then when we came to that
the the big question was what will these
people be doing
the future depends on us to a great
extent
but even if we propose to do the best of
things
this government from this country must
usually then interferes to frustrate our
plans
look what is happening in guatemala
today there's
hardly a country in the world where you
have a worse
human rights situation who is to blame
finally after a long struggle the
guatemalans under arabians were
beginning to undertake the necessary
steps for the reforms that were
long overdue in guatemala
it was a democratically elected
government it was
very well written book bitter fruit by
stephen kinser
and um and the united states decided to
overthrow
armaments and they're always doing that
and so
we we don't have a chance
these enemies they speak so much about
democracy
how can anyone who would not even allow
us independence
say that they're interested in democracy
independence by itself
does not lead to democracy but it is
indeed an
absolute indispensable prerequisite for
it
can we ask you about the cultural war
and george bush
we've read in the united states and the
rolling stone in an article called the
dirty secrets of george bush
that it was bush himself and not oliver
north who was initially
leading the illegal project of arming
the countries
of giving weapons to the contras to
fight the sandinista government
at a time when congress forbid
u.s arms being used for given to the
contrast and we heard that bush himself
was part of this project to fund
the contras did you get those stories in
nicaragua and what is your sense
of the country war of who was leading it
and what its purposes were
well we
certainly never ever
trusted bush we knew who he was and we
know the degree of his commitment
and and reagan
well to me it was a clinical case
i mean reagan was obsessed but
pathologically obsessed it's insane that
he should have dedicated more time to
nicaragua than to
any other single international issue
it is insane it really is no i think it
i don't mean any
lag respect for a human being but i
think he should have been instead of
reelected he should have been committed
but at any rate
initially what was the purpose of the
contra war
initially when reagan first put it
together
the objective was the military overthrow
of the sandinistas
that's why tormenters got in
into problems and eventually was
kicked out because he was insisting what
here the euphemistically referred to at
the two-track
diplomacy they used to call it a carrot
and stick
and reagan says no no carrots on the
sticks
and so and so but after
the contra and they really thought it
was going to be a quick thing
remember how they hooked honduras into
going along
honduras was reluctant not out of
principle out of fear
they were reluctant to go with the
united states in this in the
honduras the united states said look in
one month
time we will have conquered the sizable
part of northern nicaragua with the city
we will have a government there that we
will
recognize and our friends our other
democratic friends
like paraguay and god knows what else
will
give recognition to that government
making it quite legitimate
for us and we will move in
and give them support and whatever but
they promised honduras that at any rate
this would never take more than three
months
and in 10 years they never got one inch
of one city for
for one day so
after already within the first term of
president reagan he realized
that the countries were not going to be
able to achieve the purpose for which
they were
created but he nonetheless chose to
maintain it
because the main objective as roy
gottman
has well documented and and people
like peter cornblue from the central
american archives in washington
the main objective was the destruction
of the nicaraguan economy
the contrast would help towards that
right
and and then you have the contrast and
the destruction of the economy which
itself
according to this theory then it would
bring
the discontent among the people and the
people that would be an uprising
and then maybe you can get the honduran
army
and god knows what and and then get rid
of
do every repeat of what they did in we
would lea in 1934
wipe out this sandinista i think one
reason particularly they were aiming at
the economy was not only to
create a lot of discontent among the
people
so that the son and nieces would lose
their support but also
it was very dangerous to the united
states the fact that the san anista
economy
had flourished before the u.s
intervention it was the
uh had the largest growth rate in the uh
in the hemisphere in the first two years
of the revolution
and then we were a bad example that you
were being independent
of american economic interests and
governing your own economy
in the interest of your own people
that's very bad miguel that's the
title of a book from published in
england
about nicaragua the title is nicaragua
the threat of a good example
that's correct can i ask a question
about noriega
that's part of the cultural war noriego
is working with
the reagan administration to supply the
contras
etc uh on the other hand there were also
rumors that noriega
was friendly to cuba and nicaragua that
he was playing both sides
of the street so to speak any
leader any government official or head
of state
if he's going to be a good asset for the
cia
must play it both ways must have it's
not going to be efficient if it doesn't
have relations right
true so that's not surprising and it is
true that nordier had these
relationships and
and what is also true is that
whatever he did in regards to drugs and
that
was it was the full approval
and knowledge of this government who
usually plays the role of the
international hooker
yeah just to to have a greater
possibility of control
and so and
mr hooker is in the president of the
united states i may be kicked out
for saying that but
so i say that because i believe it
and how do i see the invasion of panama
it's gross unbelievable
uh
it it proves what conor cruz o'brien
says in his book recently published by
harvard university press
guideland he says that the problem
is that the united states doesn't feel
so much to be
the appointed by god to do something
it has reached the the point where
of the deification of the state it
is itself god and therefore above any
law human or divine
and so they they invade the country and
and they do it just to save democracy
and uh sad
but that's why i say at this point in
time and for some time in the past
the united states is behaving as a
plague in humanity as a plague for those
who really want freedom or really want
independence and who really want
democracy
these people mention these words only to
dirty
concepts that are very good and deserve
to be respected and
practiced and so i hope someday
that the american people will wake up
and really show me that they love their
country more than they love their
individual
selfish objects and begin to exert
a leavening action within their own
country
i remember as a foreign minister
other foreign ministers sometimes
in a patronizing sort of way would say
to me you know father
what a possible good can come to
nicaragua
from this uneven struggle
why don't you forget about it all and
you know
and then i would answer
what would be the future of the world
if there were not countries willing to
stand up
regardless of what happened to us
christ was crucified
and i thank those who stand up
dr king was killed mahatma gandhi was
girl
our country was sentenced to death
by the united states because we
committed the heresy
of saying that we upheld the principle
of suffering and legal equality of all
nations
regardless of territorial dimensions or
economic or military might and this
according to this
u.s state religion is heresy and we must
be burned to death
with the collapse of the soviet union
and the eastern bloc of countries
there is no there's no recourse there's
no
body to help any of these smaller
countries and with the abdication of
europe europe has become a great big
supermarket
because europe the european countries
were helping nicaragua for a while yeah
but
i i saw it in the gulf war i mean the
golf world need not being i remember
talking to people like president
mitterrand why not say it
and to andre orti and they've gone to
bonn and go on
not only to king hussein but to other
capitals and then to saddam hussein for
a long time
and i realized that there was no need at
all for any war
i not that i'm justifying certain
actions or the
taking over of kuwait but there are
means
for peaceful settlement of controversies
but the united states
wanted to expedite that process because
they wanted to try
out the new hatari in this country
that presents itself as a beacon of
uprightness
to the world became involving an obscene
orgy of blood
and the american people rabbled in it
and that's a shame
it was the first pornographic spectacle
that you could ever imagine sheer
pornography
the way the american people rabbled
and they presented the crimes that were
being perpetrated as the latest
atari game for getting that behind those
dots
and behind those lights whatever you saw
there on television it was real people
who died right
and we talked about uh a couple of more
subjects and the time we have left can
you tell us about the elections which
took place
uh in which san anista's lost which the
u.s
intervened so heavily can you tell us
about that process
we advanced the elections
by almost a year
and yes i i can share with you that i
was initially the one to recommend
to president ortega that would do so my
responsibility was foreign relations and
i said look
maybe this fellow is different from bush
from
reagan many times
as a result of my conversations with
your senators
we would do certain things in such a way
as to enable reagan
to step off and say that he won
claim victory we would do certain things
it was served for him to say
because the the the the senators will
tell me
uh father he needs to save face
so don't make it too hard do this thing
and do this that and do that
things that we were going to do anyway
they had no that was not
in contradiction with our principles and
and so we would do it
but i told the senators before forget it
i'll do it so that you will
know something more about your own
government and your president to show
you and eventually they came to tell me
father you're right never again i will
going to ask you
for a gesture you were right to begin
with
and but i said
i told daniel i said maybe this felt a
bush
is different let's try him out and then
i said
maybe if we have the elections quickly
uh
that but i said do not expect that he
would even talk to us even if we
say that we're going to advance the
elections he will invite to the oval
office i said whoever is his choice
but i had no clue ever that it was going
to be mr chamorro
but but i did guess that there were
going to be picture opportunities
as means of of pressuring the people and
saying this is my anointing when this is
my chosen one
you choose heroin will pardon your life
you choose the other one and we will
continue to kill you
that was what happened and they say
there were free elections and
the people went to vote with a gun in
their heads
because and yet what is amazing is the
41 percent of the people said okay go
ahead and kill me
and they voted for the under
circumstances that's a very high because
they believed in the sandinistas and
what you had
attempted to do for the country yes now
what is happening is again
is surreal because the united states put
together this coalition called uno
union
an unbelievable assortment of the most
radical
they call it the the movement for
popular action marxist leninist
communist party social disparity and
then you move more towards the center
and then to the extreme right
and they all together make this uno and
then
they were told how to run a convention
in which you elect a candidate
was popcorning all the trimmings of
american and so
and they took it seriously and they
thought they were free to choose their
own candidate
and they had the first voting and mr
camaro only got two votes
you needed at least eight someone who
represented private enterprise got six
his name is bolanos and then virgil
who is the president vice president got
six
and then is worried they sent down an
emissary
but anyway they had a second round of
votes it was a repeat performance
mrs chamorro is about to withdraw to
free those two
so that maybe the stalemate could be
resolved
the state department says no mrs
chamorro is the candidate otherwise
there is no help
economic help for the elections or after
and so she wasn't really freely chosen
gold oil fields the man who is the vice
president that the presidency was stolen
from him
he is committed to the overthrow of mrs
chamorro
the the unoppo coalition is against her
almost all of them the real base of
support of mrs yamuro is the
san francisco we want stability we want
and so it is surreal and the other
people feel
betrayed by the united states because
they they talked about so much money
that was going to be given
and they're giving crumbs the the
international
team of experts remarks from from
harvard and
and from the united nations economic
commission for latin america from ikla
they established the the amount of of
damage caused
by 17 billion dollars and the workhorse
said that the united states had to pay
for reparations for damages and
but they pressure mrs chamorro into
forgiving the united states what a
shameful thing
and she with her bourgeois logic went on
television and said it is not good
manners
to ask a friend to pay up so we are
forgiven the united states because they
are so good
they are so good to her she feels
indebted because
she is present but anyway we have to put
that behind us
we got to see now how while the united
states is looking in another direction
we'll bring the nicaraguan family
together we work for the interest not of
the party but of the people
and and things are moving i think
in this direction although the hardships
are great
well also they've dismantled a lot of
the gains made by the sandinistas are
they not
yes but and they threatened to dismantle
more
but they haven't made well certainly in
education
certainly in health and land reform and
they're letting the old land owners
know they're not really no not that that
has been stopped
okay and we have had good gains in that
area because for example
they come out with this idea of
privatization
as if it was something new we were
little by little
pushing this for years and we would have
continued and and we said we are not
against privatization or
on the country we're for it but
privatization don't forget that the
poor people are also part of the public
who should have an
option to to buying a part
into on those enterprises and we
insisted on
at least in the sugar industry on 25
going to the pool
that they not be redlined and prevented
from
from credit to to buy and we got it and
then the big battle
these last few days has been that
we didn't want the worst 25 because some
of those sugar mills are
run down and not good and and then you
have others that are very modern and
sophisticated and
great and then if they had it their way
they would be the workers would have
gotten the bad ones no they got the
better ones
so you do that at the role of different
now is to be a kind of a mediator
between the people that are every day
better organized and in the government
and now the government has asked
different san diego
to prepare by june
of 92 a proposal
on how to mitigate
the suffering of the poor which results
from the economic adjustment measures
how to
how to more equitably and justly
distribute
the the sacrifice as it were of the
bell tightening policies
so you're fairly hopeful of the future
of your country then
i am an incredible optimist in spite of
all the things i
i believe in god and that means i
believe in people and i believe in
history and i believe
and our people are valiant
i don't believe that things happen by
themselves right
we've got to get we got to do it
but i i do i work every day as a
community organizer
for the empowerment of the people that
in the slums
and it is there that i get my
renewed faith and and optimism
in spite of the fact that the suffering
is huge and that i cannot
ignore the fact that any other country
was the same kind of social
pressure what you would be reading about
is looting of
of supermarkets and bombings and
and tanks coming out and i i just
hope that we are able to
to to to lessen that tension because
everything human is limited and finite
even the proverbial patience of the
nicaraguan people